le journal du dimanche a réalisé une
enquête sur thierry ardisson et dans
cette enquête on peut découvrir le
salaire que touche tir ardisson entre
quinze et vingt mille euros par mois et
mais les propos qui font pas mal parlé
depuis la publication de cet article
c'est quand tu iras 10 on évoque son
rapport à l'argent alors vous allez nous
dire ce que vous en pensez
et j'aimerais avoir l'avis aussi des
téléspectateurs si je fais trop de télé
au détriment d'activités plus noble
c'est que je suis vénale j'aime l'argent
être vieux c'est chiant mais être vieux
et pauvres c'est pire
franchement c'est du tir a redit qu est
ce que ça vous choque parce que voilà
c'est s'assumer le centre ville je pense
qu'ils montent sur les chiffres il ya
deux choses qui vous choque quand on a
appris quelques stéphane guillon était
payée de 10000 euros par mois ah oui
donc été le payer moins que guillon mais
en fait j'étais content j'ai pas vu le
dos à wemmel maintenant je vous jure
qu'il appartient soit 1000 par émission
alors d'automne qui les projecteurs mais
merci il avait baissé
c'est du terrorisme de baincthun c'est
bien thierry ardisson pur jus
parfaitement premier chauffeur et tout
donc on ne peut pas être un peut pas
être content
en revanche moi aussi j'ai tiqué sur le
chiffre bah ouais je sais bien que je
suis nul en chiffres mais quand même le
jeu mais je trouve ça un sens c'est
parce qu'on lui reproche d'avoir donner
un chiffre mais donner tous un chiffre
lui il a le courage de le dire
casta bien en ce moment vous m'a
supporté
[Applaudissements]
je sais ce que vous allez dire allez
dire les chips on fouille les
producteurs collègues et moi oui mais
dans l'éveil d'une année pour moi il
donne à chypre il arrive personne bien
lady a longtemps je refuse vingt mille
euros c'est de l'enfumage c'est archi
faux et ses fauves est faux c'est la
faulx siens alors les gens si j'ai
impressionné par la pseudo transparence
mais c'est pas transparent gère donc ces
jeux vous dire fou alors de jouer un mec
qui ont montré des gras sont à pau moi
j'y croirai mais ça mûrit à dire que de
mentir
là vous déplacer le débat sera là bas je
vous ai posé la question est-ce que la
phrase j'aime être vieux c'est chiant
mais trop vieux et pauvres c'est pire
est ce qu'elle vous choque ou pas vous
garder son nom au contraire il est très
franche très honnête vous aussi vous
aimez l'argent sert il n'a pas de visite
et pas l'argent mais des folles se
nommait les nobel alors light en attaque
non non non attendez j'ai alors moi j'ai
dit amélie qui quitte alors franchement
kg janice accusé dans le besoin vous
justifiez pas d'aborder ces normes et là
on se doit la version de trois étages
s'était pas déroulée de dora
l'exploratrice la descente de
l'ascenseur
[Applaudissements]
j'étais alors pour le pôle la france ça
ne choque pas du tout non mais non c'est
rien c'est ce qu'il a dit sur elle et
rolls ardisson et puis il est vrai
qu'être vieux est pauvre c'est quand
même très très chiant par action série
oui tous les âges donc c'est ça qui est
génial c'est bon ça évidemment non mais
je sais que j'ai déplacé ou pas voilà
c'est une référence à la fameuse phrase
vaut mieux être riche et bien portant
que pauvre et malade
c'est la réponse est non merci on a des
hausses à venir
attendez pas si les gars de l'opt
dérision la wii à 6 mais où est ce que
ça me choque voilà bah kelly non mais
voilà les gens voient la presse et qui
est un préliminaire après je pas le
féliciter parce qu'il est content d'être
arrogant je me les normes c'est son
style en plus tirés mais pas moi il
adore provoquer lui en fait les dents la
visite du tout comme ça c'est vrai il
est issu j'avais sur servier a voyagé
fait appel
voilà vous l'avez vu tout de suite vous
aimez là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
commencer